التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث افاد حاكم مقاطعه بيلجورود
الروسيه
بمقتل شخصين واصابه اخرين في قصف اوكراني
استهدف مناطق سكنيه عده في المقاطعه كما
اعلنا حاكم
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا والتي تعرضت لقصف
اوكرانيا الى مراكز ايواء مؤقته واضاف ان
اقامه عددا كبيرا من الاسر والاطفال في
منشاه الرياضيه ضخمه امر في غايه الصعوبه
لافتا الانتباه الى ان السلطات تبحث نقلها
هؤلاء الى اماكنها اكثر راحه واشار الحكيم
الى ان مقاطعه بيلجوروت شهدت هدوء نسبيا
الليله الماضيه مع استمرار القصف على
منطقه شيب كينسكي
وفي روسيا اعلنا حاكم مقاطعه كورسكا
الروسيه ان الدفاعات الجويه تصدت لعده
مسيرات اوكرانيه فوق مدينه عاصمه المقاطعه
وفي روسيا ايضا اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بريانس
كاليكساندر بوجوميز ان قريه لوما كوفكال
حدوديه مع اوكرانيا تعرضت لقصف من القوات
الاوكرانيه وقال بوغماز ان القصف ادى الى
شعار النيران في مبنى سكني دون وقوع خسائر
بشريه
كما اعلن حاكم مقاطعه
الروسيه ان طائرتين مسيرتين هجمتان مصفاه
لتكرير النفط في المقاطعه المحاذيه
لبيلاروسيا دون تسجيل اضرار تذكر بدوره
قال حاكم ومقاطعه الروسيه ان الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت طائرتا طائره مسيره اوكرانيه
فوق غابه المقاطعه كمان ايضا التطورات في
الساعات الاخيره
[موسيقى]
سلمى لا يمكن استثناء اي منطقه من هذا
الشريط الحدودي بين روسيا واوكرانيا من
هذه المعارك والاستهدافات الضاريه اذا ما
وضعنا نقاط الاستهدافات كان من الجهه
الاوكرانيه او من الجهه الروسيه نتبين ان
هذا الشريط ملتهب جدا المقاطعات الحدوديه
الروسيه تتعرض لقصف واستهدافات بالمصيرات
كورسك بريانس قبل قليل اعلن الحاكم عن
مقتل امراتين في تلك المقاطعه الحدوديه
الشرق ايضا وجبهات الشرق ملتهبه بشكل كبير
قبل قليل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت عن
تحركات وعن الخطوات وتدميرها لالويه
اوكرانيه كان على محور مارينكا او على
محور في دنياسك حيث نتواجد ونسمع كثيرا
ارتداد هذا القصف على مدينه ووسط مدينه
دنيتك احيانا تتصدى له الدفاعات الجويه
واحيانا تسقط صواريخ في بعض الاحياء
وهو ماده الى جرح اشخاص ومقتل ثلاثه اشخاص
يوم امس في هذه الحصيله التي اعلنتها
السلطات المحليه يمتد هذا الاستهداف جنوبا
الى خرسون وباروجيا قبل قليل كان هناك
اعلان على وسائل الاعلام المحليه الروسيه
عن استهداف اوكراني لبريديانسك هذه
المقاطعه التي تقع على بحر ازوف فيزا وتم
الحديث عن تصدي الدفاعات الجويه لقصف
اوكراني في تلك المقاطعه في زفروجيا ايضا
يمتد القتال على مدى كل هذه الجبهات ولكن
اليوم اذا قلنا وتحدثنا عن التحديات
الابرز بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه التي تقاتل
على عدد من الجبهات بيل تشكل اهميه كبرى
وترتد هذه الاهميه على كوبيانز في خار كيف
حيث تقول السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
خارقه ان هناك مسعا من القوات الروسيه
لتمددها ايضا هناك مسعا من قبل القوات
الروسيه لاحكام واطباق السيطره على ما
تبقى من جبهات في دانيت تحدثت وحدات احمد
الشيشانيه وقائد هذه الوحدات عن تقدم لهذه
المجموعات القتاليه بالاضافه الى القوات
الروسيه على محور مارينكا هناك قتال مستعر
تحدثت ايضا عنه وزاره الدفاع ايضا اليوم
كل هذه المنطقه ملتهبه يمكن القول يمكن
القول ان هناك مرحله جديده في هذه الحرب
التي بدات قبل اكثر من نحو عام في
اوكرانيا وفي هذه المقاطعات الحدوديه
عنوانها كل هذه الجبهات ولكن ايضا عنوان
اضافي فيها هو مرتبط بالمقاطعات الحدوديه
تاكيدات من الكريم على ضروره اتخاذ
اجراءات للتعامل مع هذه الهجومات المتكرره
على هذه المقاطعات الحدوديه ولكن لغايه
الان يبدو ان القوات الروسيه وتحديدا في
مقاطعه بلغ جروت تنحو باتجاه تحركات
عسكريه وهو مطلب كان قد تحدث عنه حاكم
المقاطعه الذي قال ان الحل الوحيد هو بضم
خارج شكرا لك يا كارمن جو خضار مراسلتنا
من دوني